three months ago he called us and told
us that he was in tax debt to the IRS
again and wanted his mom and I to uh
bail him out basically using our share
of his of of our estate when we die uh
we thought he' probably owe about 50 or
$60,000 turns out he hasn't filed any
state or federal tax returns for the
past four years nor has he paid any
estimated taxes for
2023 we're meeting with our accountant
next Thursday to go all this to get
specific numbers but I'm guessing from
what I've seen it's going to be over
$200,000 and about half of that is just
interest and penalties he also hasn't
paid any 941 withholding or state
unemployment tax so my question is uh we
have the assets to do that but we would
have to sell off property and mutual
funds